foreign
Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm spending the next four days
camping in these woods but I'm not just
camping me and my trusty mini bike we're
gonna be cutting a quarter mile of fresh
Trail through these Woods to try to get
to a really awesome Little River and at
the end of this camp out my family's
gonna come down and join me and we're
gonna have an awesome Family Camp Out
come along for the ride we're gonna have
a great time
foreign
guys we're doing something a little
different today I'm going to take my
little motorcycle and we're going to cut
our way straight through there all the
way to a river and we're going to be
camping and bushwhacking until we get
there
[Music]
out in Stormy Weather I
[Music]
you might think you'll see me
falling to the ground but I threw up my
umbrella when rain stopped sitting down
yeah
on a bad day
on a good day
[Music]
like
Sunshine cause I'm dancing
[Music]
we're making some really good progress
but it's a real trick to stay on course
[Music]
oh popped my chain it's time to switch
it out anyways
I'm gonna take a little snack break here
chocolate moon pie pretty good
all right back to work I'm just waiting
through massive amounts of poison ivy
here that's poison ivy that's poison ivy
that's poison ivy all this little green
plant down here is all poison ivy for
whatever reason I've just never had a
bad poison ivy reaction so knock on wood
I won't have one today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
's getting pretty low and I'm exhausted
and so hungry I think this would make a
great spot to camp
I think that's exactly what I'm gonna do
now I've got to hike back to the
beginning of the trail and go get the
motorcycle and all my camping gear
oh
man I got it done today I think I did a
quarter of a mile
man that was a hike
why I'm starving but luckily I've got
plenty of firewood to start a fire with
so we're gonna get dinner cooking pretty
quick here
foreign
[Music]
with my blast match it's just a ferrous
rod on a spring there's a bit of Steel
on this tab and when you go and you
smash it make sparks it's got a little
cotton ball right here
got to this double hammock I'm going to
be sleeping in tonight
it's actually really comfortable when
it's hot and humid like it is right now
a hammock's hard to beat
now a lot of people like to set up their
hammock really saggy and sleep sideways
in it but I'm six foot four and that
doesn't really work that well for me so
I String my hammock super tight and then
I sleep in it this way if you string it
up super tight you don't sag in so much
and it doesn't bend your knees backwards
all right
[Music]
all right
wow
[Music]
[Music]
all right
time to make some dinner I'm gonna make
some bread
got some bread flour yeast and sugar in
this bag here
just gonna add a little water to it that
yeast going
all right let that ferment a little bit
we're gonna have bread in no time
so we're gonna have something delicious
today I've got some white bratwurst some
mustard some sauerkraut and some hot
sauce we're gonna cook up the best
campfire brats ever
gonna slow cook that broth
foreign
[Music]
loving the sauerkraut hot sauce Zach
Fowler's a fellow YouTuber and friend of
mine he's got a signature brand Chipotle
hot sauce it's actually pretty good
campfire broth look at that I love white
brats this thing's Tangy and good and oh
that is the best campfire hot dog I've
ever had
yeah I'm definitely making another one
of those
oh that's perfect
oh another Beauty
and I am so hungry
oh feels good to have some food in my
belly
get the bug net pulled over the hammock
all right you got the bug net over the
hammock so I won't be eating Alive
Tonight speaking of bugs let me show you
something
I hope these Woods are just full of big
old spiders when you wear a headlamp you
can see their eyes twinkling in the dark
it's really hard to see on the camera
but there's a spider there's one
crawling up the tree
there's one right there oh that's a big
one I can see his eyes right there
there's one you go outside at night with
a high-powered headlamp you'll see all
the spider eyes staring back at you
there's hundreds of them that's a pretty
good sized mole cricket look at that
I brought a tarp just in case it rains
but it is so clear tonight I don't think
I'll need it I'm just going to sleep
under the stars
that is one stinky shirt hopefully it'll
dry out tonight
I'm gonna button it down for the night
and uh I will see you guys in the
morning
oh my goodness I'm sore no it's 9 30.
all right I think it's time to get the
fire started
all right let's get some breakfast going
I've got eggs and Scrapple
now if you're not from Delaware you
might be asking what is scrapple it is
assorted pork products allow me to read
the ingredients pork stock porks liver
pork fat pork skins white cornmeal pork
Hearts wheat flour salt spices
so it's uh pork scraps squished into a
block and it's called scrapple and it's
actually really good and it's a
traditional Regional food over in
Delaware
well don't be put off by the gray color
that's natural
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there we go scrapple in eggs with honey
butter flat bread that is the Breakfast
of Champions right there
scrapple has this really smooth texture
and it has the flavor of homemade
stuffing like if you put it inside the
actual turkey stuffing it's it's really
good and with a little bit of Honey or
maple syrup it's fabulous
yeah I'm making a little scrapple Taco
um kind of a Delaware Mexican Fusion
dish
I thought I'd cook too much food but uh
turns out it was just fine
well we made really good progress
yesterday so we are more than halfway
done with cutting this Trail now mind
you we've got a lot more to do than just
cut the trail
but uh hopefully we'll get to the river
pretty soon here but I better get to
work
[Music]
hmm
look at this
hey somebody's old deer stand
we linked up with an old road
and also we found the river I've wanted
to fish and explore that River for some
time but I've had no way to access it so
that's a big part of why I'm doing what
I'm doing well I still got a couple
hundred yards to go this way along the
river and there's a lot of downed trees
over this old 4x4 Trail so better get to
work
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well my chainsaw made a funny noise and
I'm no mechanic but I think that's not
supposed to be like that that that looks
bad
well I think I need to hop on the
motorcycle driving to town and get
another chainsaw cause uh this one's
gonna be out of commission for a little
bit probably hold on to these these look
important
uh you know that looks broken
there we go got all of our pieces
getting ready to leave to fix the
chainsaw and the wind just shifted and
the temperature dropped we might have a
storm coming in I've got to get
everything buttoned down before I leave
[Music]
three hours later
[Applause]
[Music]
I grabbed this little 250 while my Farm
Boss is getting repaired
look how shiny and new this thing is oh
that won't last long
is it just me or does the gas cap on
steel chainsaws look just like a
Pokeball
I'm gonna be the best chainsaw trainer
ever
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
River love to bring the kids down here
and swim in it and fish in it need to do
a little bit more cleanup first
this is such a lovely spot I could just
sit here forever and watch the water go
by but uh I still got work to do
well this Trail is pretty awesome but
there's still a lot of poison ivy and
brambles around now you got to do
something about that so that's my next
step I didn't want to strap this to the
motorcycle so I did a little 20 minute
walk got myself a weed whacker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well if this thing wasn't breaking every
few minutes I'd get done pretty quick
but
this really wasn't designed for this
thick of brush
oh well that's what we got
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it I'm out of line I had a brand
new spool of line on this weed eater
when I came here and I just used it all
up this stuff just chewed up my line
but I got 99 of it done it's about time
to quit anyways we're running out of
sunlight I am hungry
we're gonna get this going
all right gotta let that fire burn down
until we get a big pile of coals then
we're gonna start cooking ribs
all right I got some seasoned pork ribs
wrapped up in tin foil here I'm gonna
pull that fire apart throw some coals on
top throw some coals underneath it's
gonna be delicious
all right let that sit for about an hour
let it cook nice and slow
oh
that doesn't look bad at all does that
all falling apart yeah I think we nailed
it oh
got a nice slab of cornbread to go with
my ribs
I think I'm gonna add some honey and
butter to my cornbread
oh just a little bit of honey oh that's
so good tin foil ribs are so easy and so
delicious
hmm
yeah you know I'm not going to stay up
super late tonight I want to get plenty
of sleep because my family's coming to
join me we're gonna have a little camp
out as a family down here and Becca and
the kids are gonna get to see the river
and and uh we've got a couple fun things
planned it's gonna be really cool
definitely feels like it might storm
tonight so I've got the tarp buttoned
down pretty tight I gotta go and get all
my tools and put it under the tarp
before I go to bed the wind's really
starting to kick up I think I better put
the fire out I don't want Sparks blowing
around
[ __ ]
ing
alrighty
all right guys it's getting late and
this storm's kicking up uh hopefully it
will become an issue but I'll see you
guys in the morning
well good morning guys after that storm
front blew through the temperature
dropped it it is cold
oh I gotta get out of bed and start a
fire
foreign
just sitting here by the fire rubbing
all my mosquito bites and checking all
my War wounds I mean look at my forearm
those brambles are Savage and look at
some of these mosquito bites man that is
a huge one there's a lot more than that
but you don't want to see them all
oh I hate putting on cold pants
yeah
for breakfast we've got leftover
scrapple
oh
scrapple is not one of those Foods where
the two second rule applies stuff like
that does happen from time to time so I
always bring a backup meal
we got cold cereal powdered milk
dehydrated raspberries Just Add Water
cereal I was looking forward to that
scrapple too
there we go I wouldn't recommend
drinking powdered milk straight but on
cereal it gets the job done
well it's not fried scrapple but it's
good
I'm gonna make myself a cup of tea here
you can put whatever you want in here
but I'm gonna do some Peach herbal tea
foreign we'll just let that seep for
about five minutes and they'll be ready
to drink
[Music]
some sugar oh man I really like this mug
I made it from a cowhorn I've been using
it a lot lately it's very manly
it's actually a really easy project I
did a video on it
I've had a great time but I miss my
little boys and I'm excited to show them
the trail and the river and have them
play on the motorcycle and of course I'm
gonna bring you guys along for the ride
so don't worry I'll film it
thank you
later that same evening
wanna go do some camping with Dad
you guys want to ride our new ATV trail
who wants to help me build the fire
oh
[Music]
whoa
guys is that cool yeah mom was that cool
apparently the Y chromosome is necessary
to enjoy gasoline fireballs
[Music]
[Music]
ah
hey guys look like we got some friends
joining us we made it hey guys
I'm like class my friends
all right guys who wants to make s'mores
and roast marshmallows come on yeah
there you go how about that that one
that's perfect Jacob one
I'll blow it
like you combine uranium with TNT and I
just can't be like this more
is that a mouthful of marshmallows you
got there yeah Becca are you having a
good night
well it's super late and the kids are
full of marshmallows I think it's time
to get them down to bed if we can manage
it oh boy
they've gone nuts
here get on in there oh you had so many
marshmallows
Financial release
this sure is nice isn't it big
I brought a negative 20 degree bag for
Becca and I'm gonna put a hot water
bottle in it to keep her warm
and that will not be too much rehearse
she can get cold anywhere
foreign
everybody
[Music]
oh it tastes like a mouse died in my
mouth
if you don't want
to
warm things
all right there we go
we got a little after breakfast rice
pudding snack
you guys want to cook some eggs and fire
Ash
yeah
give me a shot
is Tommy awake
give that about 5-10 minutes
hey bud how you doing
go use the body
oh yes
when you're cooking campfire eggs you
want to bury them in the white ash not
the charcoals the charcoals are a lot
hotter than the ash if you just throw a
whole bunch of coals around them they'll
get too hot too quick and then the eggs
pop there you go there's some hot herbal
tea oh my goodness thank you is that
your first time drinking from the cow
horn it is
what is going on over there oh my
goodness it's just like this folds an
egg into a helmet he's easy
we're grateful for that he's eating all
right guys I'm well fed and well rested
and I think I need to do some work here
and I'm gonna try to cut a path through
there now I have a trail that leads to
the ATV trail I just made but those
trees have fallen over the front of it
so I need to just cut through that to
get to the old path to get to the New
Path anyway I'm gonna do some chopping
[Music]
look at this
see how it's so cute
okay let's take him over here there we
go
that looks like an Eastern Box Turtle ah
cute little guy we'll just let him go
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh my goodness what are you doing up
there
oh my goodness you're way up there
all right we're gonna make some hot dogs
get this fire going here
oh that looks good very much
sweet onion relish bratwurst there we go
Jacob's lizard's just been hanging out
on his back for like the last 45 minutes
still there
it's a Jacob lizard now
hey Becca hi this video how's it going
it's going well I finished the trail you
want to come check it out all right guys
you want to go to the river
yeah
I should just be happy to
well you guys want to cross the river
with me
come on please go for it
okay that's really cute don't do
anything interesting out of frame I will
show you the world yeah yeah oh my
goodness look at that frog I got the
biggest one
of me
well I
oh well this is a pretty cool spot we
got shade and frogs to catch and water
to play in so what do you think Becca
you glad you made the trail yeah
oh that looks cold Jake it is but I'm
actually like
dunking your child upside down like a
little baby Achilles
it's been a fun day but I think it's
time to clean up
well thanks for coming lay the six on
the feet
hey guys did you have fun yeah if you
want to see more videos from the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning all right see you guys
then if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]